>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
WE'VE BEEN WATCHING THIS STORY
ALL WEEKEND.
LAST FRIDAY MORNING AS YOU KNOW
AROUND 2:00 A.M. POLICE ARRIVED
AT THE HOME OF THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE NANCY PELOSI, IT'S IN
THE PACIFIC HEIGHTS NEIGHBORHOOD
OF SAN FRANCISCO.
INSIDE THE HOME THEY FOUND
PELOSI'S 82 YEAR OLD HUSBAND
PAUL AND ANOTHER MAN 40 YEARS
YOUNGER CALLED DAVID.
IN FULL VIEW OF THE POLICE PHE
HIT PAUL PELOSI IN THE HEAD TWO
TIMES WITH A HAMMER.
BOTH PELOSI AND DEPAPPY WERE
TAKEN IMMEDIATELY TO A HOSPITAL,
PELOSI FOR HIS HEAD INJURIES AND
DEPAPPY FOR REASONS STILL NOT
CLEAR.
HE WAS LATER CHARGED IN FEDERAL
COURT WITH ASSAULT AND ATTEMPTED
KIDNAPPING.
AT THIS POINT THAT'S WHAT WE CAN
SAY FOR CERTAIN.
DAVID DEPAPI ASSAULTED PAUL
PELOSI WITH A HAMMER AND
APPARENTLY ADMITTED THAT IN
POLICE CUSTODY.
BUT BEYOND THOSE FACTS THERE IS
MUCH IN THE STORY THAT REMAINS
MUDDY.
HOW IN FACT DID DEPAPI GET
INSIDE THE HOME.
THAT'S THE FIRST QUESTION.
LAST YEAR THEY REPORTED SHE HAS
PROTECTION AROUND THE CLOCK AT
HER HOUSES, HER OWN SECURITY,
THEY HAVE SECURITY POLICE THAT
FLY OUT WITH HER.
BUT IN THIS INSTANCE THEY SAY
THERE WAS NO SECURITY PRESENT AT
THE PELOSI HOME ON FRIDAY NIGHT.
AND THAT'S PRETTY STRANGE
BECAUSE ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE
ACCOUNTS EVEN WHEN PELOSI ISN'T
AT HOME HER HOUSE IS WELL
GUARDED AS YOU WOULD EXPECT.
HARMEET DHILLON TOLD US WHEN HER
FIRM TRIED TO SERVE A LAWSUIT
AGAINST PAUL PELOSI, ALL OF THEM
WERE GUARDED BY MULTIPLE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ON THE
PERIMETER.
SO HOW DID DEPAPI GET PAST
SECURITY?
THAT APPARENTLY WASN'T THERE?
AND WHY WASN'T IT THERE IF, IN
FACT, IT WASN'T?
WE KNOW HE GOT INSIDE AND ONCE
HE WAS INSIDE WHAT EXACTLY
HAPPENED NEXT?
WELL, ACCOUNTS OF THAT ARE
CHANGING.
AT THE FIRST PRESS CONFERENCE ON
FRIDAY, SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
SUGGESTED THERE WAS A THIRD
PERSON IN THE HOME WHEN POLICE
ARRIVED.
AND POLITICO DUTIFULLY REPORTED
THAT.
QUOTE, OFFICERS ARRIVED AT THE
HOUSE, KNOCKED ON THE FRONT DOOR
AND WERE LET INSIDE BY AN
UNKNOWN PERSON.
IN OTHER WORDS, BY A PERSON WHO
WAS NOT DAVID DEPAPI OR PAUL
PELOSI.
POLITICO NEVER FORMALLY
CORRECTED THIS CLAIM.
INSTEAD TWO DAYS LATER POLITICO,
THE SAME PUBLICATION ATTACKED
ANYONE WHO REPEATED ITS OWN
REPORTING AS A CRAZED CONSPIRACY
MONDAYINGER.
PROCEED TRUMP COMMENTATORS
WEIGHED IN ON LINE TO RAISE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION BASED ON UNFOUNDED
AND FALSE CLAIMS.
AMONG THOSE BASELESS CLAIMS THAT
A THIRD PERSON ANSWERED THE DOOR
WHEN THE POLICE ARRIVED AT THE
HOME.
ALL RIGHT, THREE SEPARATE
ADJECTIVES KNOCKING DOWN THE
IDEA.
BUT THE QUESTION REMAINS, WAS
THERE A THIRD PERSON AT THE
HOME?
WE DON'T KNOW BUT IT'S NOT CRAZY
TO ASSUME THERE WAS.
HERE'S HOW TODAY'S CHARGING
DOCUMENTS DESCRIBE THE SCENE
INSIDE THE HOUSE.
QUOTE, WHEN THE DOOR WAS OPENED,
PELOSI AND DEPAPI WERE BOTH
HOLDING A HAMMER WITH ONE HAND
AND DEPAPI HAD HIS OTHER HAND ON
PELOSI'S FOREARM.
THE OFFICERS ASKED HIM WHAT WAS
GOING AND DEPAPI SAID EVERYTHING
WAS GOOD.
SO IT'S AN AWFUL SCENE IN SOME
WAYS BUT HERE'S THE CRITICAL
CLAUSE.
WHEN THE DOOR WAS OPENED?
WELL, OPENED BY WHOM.
COMMON SENSE SAYS IT COULDN'T
HAVE BEEN PELOSI OR DEPAPI WHO
OWNED IT THEY WERE INVOLVED IN A
LIFE AND DEAF DRAMA OVER A
HUSBAND.
THE REPORTS SAY PAUL PELOSI
NEVER HAD SEEN HIM BEFORE BUT IN
THE 911 CALL HE KNEW HIS FIRST
NAME AND APPARENTLY REFERRED TO
HIM AS A FRIEND.
HERE'S THE AUDIO FROM A
DISPATCHER RELAYING PAUL
PELOSI'S CALL.
>> THERE'S A MALE IN THE HOME
AND HE'S GOING TO WAIT FOR HIS
WIFE.
HE SAYS HE DOESN'T KNOW WHO THE
MALE IS BUT ADVISED HIS NAME IS
DAVID AND THAT HE IS A FRIEND.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN EXACTLY?
WELL, AGAIN WE DON'T KNOW AND WE
CAN'T KNOW.
WE DO KNOW THAT ANYONE WHO'S
EVER MET PAUL PELOSI CAN TELL
YOU HE'S AN AWFULLY NICE MAN,
WARM AND FRIENDLY AND CERTAINLY
DIDN'T DESERVE TO BE HIT IN THE
HEAD WITH A HAMMER, IT'S
HORRIFYING THAT HE WAS.
BUT AS LONG AS THIS IS A NEWS
STORY WITH PUBLIC POLICY
IMPLICATIONS AND UNFORTUNATELY
THAT'S WHAT IT'S BECOME, IT IS
FAIR TO ASK THE OBVIOUS
QUESTIONS AS YOU WOULD ABOUT ANY
OTHER VIOLENT CRIME THAT OCCURS
IN AMERICA, AND ESPECIALLY THIS
ONE SINCE SO MANY FACTS, BASIC
FACTS SEEM TO BE IN DISPUTE.
LOCAL KTVU INVESTIGATE I HAVE
REPORTER EVAN FOR EXAMPLE
INITIALLY REPORTED DEPAPI WAS
FOUND IN UNDERWEAR WHEN POLICE
ARRIVED.
TODAY THEY MADE A SPECIFIC POINT
OF RETRACTING THAT CLAIM, QUOTE,
I'M NOW TOLD BY OTHER SOURCES
THAT DEPAPI WAS NOT DRESSED ONLY
IN HIS UNDERWEAR.
OKAY.
FAIR ENOUGH.
WE WOULD BE SATISFIED WITH
EITHER EXPLANATION, NOT REALLY
OUR BUSINESS.
BUT YOU CAN'T BLAME, AND THIS IS
THE POINT, YOU CAN'T BLAME
PEOPLE WATCHING ALL OF THIS AT
HOME FOR THINKING THAT MAYBE
THERE'S SOMETHING WEIRD GOING ON
HERE.
PARTS OF THE OFFICIAL ACCOUNT
DON'T SEEM TO MAKE ANY SENSE.
SO THE SOLUTION OBVIOUSLY IS TO
RELEASE THE POLICE BODYCAM
FOOTAGE FROM LAST FRIDAY.
THAT'S OFTEN DONE IMMEDIATELY IN
CASES LIKE THIS, CASES THAT
INVOLVE HEAVY SCRUTINY.
TRANSPARENCY RESTORES THE
PUBLIC'S FAITH IN THE SYSTEM, IT
IS THE ONLY THING THAT DOES.
IN FACT THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT
OF BODYCAM TO REASSURE PEOPLE
THAT THEY CAN REALLY KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED.
TRANSPARENCY IS THE ANT DOUGHED
TO, QUOTE, MISINFORMATION.
ON THE OTHER HAND IF YOU WANT
PEOPLE TO FALL HEAD FIRST INTO
CRAZED CONSPIRACY THEORIES THEN
YOU WOULD KEEP LYING AND HIDING
THINGS.
AND YET FOR SOME REASON THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT IS
REFUSING TO RELEASE FRIDAY'S
BODYCAM VIDEOS.
WE LEARNED TODAY WHEN WE FILED A
RECORDS REQUEST.
NO CHANCE THEY SAID.
SO UNTIL WE SEE THE TAPE THERE
IS A LOT THAT WE CANNOT KNOW.
BUT THE MAIN QUESTION TONIGHT,
ONE THAT'S GOING TO AFFECT YOUR
LIFE GOING FORWARD, BECAUSE THIS
STORY WILL AFFECT YOUR LIFE, THE
QUESTION IS, WHO EXACTLY IS
DAVID DEPAPE?
MANY IN THE MEDIA SEEM
STEWEDIOUSLY UNINTERESTED.
THEY DON'T REALLY WANT TO KNOW.
AT A POLICE PRESS CONFERENCE
LAST WEEK A REPORTER WAS CAUGHT
ON A HOT MIC BEES TOLD BY
SOMEONE NOT TO DISCUSS DEPAPE IN
GREAT DETAIL.
SO IT WAS LEFT IN THE END FOR A
JOURNALIST WHO DOESN'T WORK FOR
A BIG MEDIA OUTLET MICHAEL
SHELLENBERGER TO FILL IN THE
BLAVSHGS.
HE FIRST DID THE OBVIOUS HE WENT
TO WHERE DEPAPE WAS LIVING
ACROSS THE BAY THIS BERKELEY.
YOU'RE SEEING AN IMAGE OF THAT
ON YOUR SCREEN NOW.
APPARENTLY HE WAS CAMPING
FULL-TIME IN A DELAP AT A TIMED
SCHOOL BUS COMPLETE WITH A GAY
PRIDE FLAG OUT FRONT AND A SIGN
THAT READS BERKELEY STANDS
ACROSS HATE.
BEHIND THE BUS HANGS A BLM
BANNER.
SO POLITICALLY THIS PICTURE
COULD NOT BE CLEARER.
YOU KNOW WHERE THIS GUY STANDS.
BUT SHELL BERGER AND OTHERS KEPT
DIGGING.
THEY FOUND DEPAPE WAS WELL KNOWN
IN THE AREA, THE ENTIRE BAY AREA
AS AN HALLUCINOGENIC DRUG
ENTHUSIAST AND A NUDIST WHO
APPEARED AT NUDIST THEMED EVENT.
DOES HE HAVE A PRIOR CRIMINAL
HISTORY?
THAT'S AN OBVIOUS AND PERHAPS
RELEVANT QUESTION BUT WE CAN'T
ANSWER IT BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN
AUTHORITIES IN SAN FRANCISCO
HAVE REFUSED TO TELL US OR
ANYONE ELSE.
WE DO KNOW THE PEOPLE AROUND
DAVID DEPAPE BELIEVE HE WAS
COMPLETELY DERANGED.
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE
INTERVIEWED HIS EX-GIRLFRIEND
WHO REPORTED THAT DEPAPE IS
MENTALLY ILL AND STRUGGLES WITH
DRUGS.
FOR EXAMPLE HE ONCE THOUGHT HE
WAS JESUS FOR A YEAR, HAS NEVER
BEEN ABLE TO HOLD A JOB, SAID
THE GIRLFRIEND.
HE WAS HOMELESS.
HE REALLY DOES SUFFER FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS AND THAT'S
PROBABLY WHY HE WAS THERE AT
2:00 A.M.
SHE DESCRIBED HIM AS A BROKEN
CHILD IN AN ADULT PROBLEM WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL PROBLEMS.
DEPAPE'S NEIGHBORS WHO KNOW SAID
MORE OR LESS THE SAME THING.
>> ANYTHING STRANGE ABOUT HIM OR
THAT WOULD STAND OUT.
>> THERE'S SOMETHING STRANGE
ABOUT THE WHOLE HOUSEHOLD, THE
ENTIRE HOUSEHOLD IS VERY
STRANGE.
>> HOW ABOUT HIM?
>> HE IS BIRDS OF A FEATHER AKIN
TO THEM.
SO THEY ARE JUST, YOU KNOW,
NUDIST DRUG ABUSERS AND THAT'S
WHO GRAVITATES TOWARDS THEM.
>> Tucker: SO JUST ANOTHER
HOMELESS MENTALLY ILL DRUG
ADDICT WITH A FONDNESS FOR BLM
NOT QUITE SO UNUSUAL IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
ONE OTHER THING ABOUT DAVID
DEPAPE, HE'S ALSO AN ILLEGAL
ALIEN ORIGINALLY FROM CANADA HAS
LONG OVERSTAYED HIS VISA SO
CURRENTLY IN THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
SO TO RESTATE THE PERPETRATOR IN
THIS VIOLENT CRIME AGAINST PAUL
PELOSI IS A MENTALLY ILL DRUG
ADDICTED ILLEGAL ALIEN NUDIST
WHO TAKES THAT LOOSE NAH
GENERALS AND LIVES IN A SCHOOL
BUS WITH A PRIDE BANNER OUT
FRONT.
SO TAKE THOSE FACTS AND LET THEM
ROLL AROUND IN YOUR BRAIN UNTIL
A RECOGNIZABLE PATTERN EMERGES.
WHAT DOES THIS SOUND LIKE TO
YOU?
IF YOU GUESSED THIS IS A
TEXTBOOK CASE OF HOME GROWN
WHITE WING EXTREMISM OBVIOUSLY
YOU'VE BEEN WATCHING A LOT OF
CABLE NEWS TODAY.
HERE'S A SELECTION.
>> IS THIS POLITICAL VIOLENCE,
IN YOUR OPINION.
>> IT SEEMS TO BE CLEAR THAT THE
CONTENT OF HIS SOCIAL MEDIA AND
THE STATEMENTS HE ALLEGEDLY MADE
ABOUT WHERE'S NANCY?
WE'RE GOING TO WAIT FOR NANCY,
CERTAINLY POINTS IN THAT
DIRECTION.
>> SEEMS LIKE THERE'S THIS
EFFORT TO NORMALIZE THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR AND MAKE TRUMPERS FEEL
AT HOME AND PRIOR TIES THEIR
FEELINGS.
>> WHAT HAS HAPPENED OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS HAS SEEPED INTO
THE MINDS AND THOUGHTS OF
UNSTABLE PEOPLE.
>> DERANGED WHITE WING FANATICS
TRUMP MEDIA ALLIES AND SOME OF
THE MOST POWERFUL PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD WERE FEVERISHLY TRYING TO
STIR UP CONSPIRACY THEORIES THAT
DISTRACTED FROM THE CENTRAL
POLITICAL HEADLINE OF THIS
STORY.
THAT YEARS OF REPUBLICAN
PROPAGANDA AND TRUMP-FUELED
FASCISM LED 42 YEAR OLD DAVID
DEPAPE TO BREAK INTO NANCY
PELOSI'S SAN FRANCISCO HOME.
>> Tucker: TO BE FAIR THE FACT
THAT SHE HAS A HIGH PAYING JOB
DOES GIVE RISE TO CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
I MEAN IN A FAIR SOCIETY HOW
COULD THAT HAPPEN?
BUT IT HAS.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IS THE MENTALLY ILL
HOMELESS ILLEGAL ALIEN DRUG
ADDICT WHO LIVES IN A PAINTED
SCHOOL BUS IN BERKELEY WITH A
BLM FLAG IS ANOTHER MEN OF
DONALD TRUMP'S QANON ARMY.
DAVID AXLE ROD PUT IT FAR RIGHT
CONSPIRACY THEORIES ARE TO BLAME
AND THE WASHINGTON POST SAID
RIGHT WING PUPS INSIGHT VIOLENCE
AGAINST THE PELOSI FAMILY USING
THIS ILLEGAL ALIEN HOMELESS GUY
ON DRUGS.
THE FAR RIGHT DEMONIZED PELOSI
AND THAT LED THE ATTACK LED THE
PATTERN ON MSNBC.
ON WHAT GROUNDS OTHER THAN
POLITICAL DESPERATION ARE THEY
SAYING THINGS LIKE THIS?
ACCORDING TO SOME REPORTS THE
HOMELESS MENTALLY I WILL DRUG
ADDICTED ILLEGAL ALIEN DAVID
DEPAPE MAINTAINED WEB SITES WITH
RIGHT WING CONTENT.
ONE SIGHT WAS APPARENTLY CALLED
FRIENDLY FRIEND.COM AND THE
STRANGE THING ABOUT THAT WEB
SITE IS THAT THE WEB ADDRESS FOR
IT WAS REGISTERED BACK IN
SEPTEMBER BUT THERE'S CONTENT ON
THE SITE THAT IS BACK DATED TO
AUGUST.
AN INTERNET AR KIND OFFING
SERVICE DIDN'T REGISTER ANY
CONTENT FROM THAT BLOG,
APPARENTLY DAVID DEPAPE'S BLOG
UNTIL OCTOBER 28TH THE DAY OF
THE ATTACK ON PAUL PELOSI.
ON OCTOBER 28TH FRIENDLY FRIENDS
SUDDENLY HAD INCOHERENT POSTS
ABOUT UFOs AND PETER NAVARRO 0.
WHAT DO THEY MIGHT?
RIGHT WING CONSPIRACY, BETTER
INDICT MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
FOR THE CRIME.
SHAKE YOUR HEAD IN BEWILDERMENT
THAT THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS ARE
NEXT TUESDAY AND THE DEMOCRATS
ARE IN TROUBLE AND THEY BELIEVE
THE ATTACK MIGHT HELP THEM.
AS MARGARET BRENNAN SAID ON CBS
BECAUSE A MENTALLY ILLEGAL I
WILL GENERAL ATTACKED NANCY
PELOSI'S HOP IT IS NOW IMMORAL
TO CRITICIZE DEMOCRATS BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
>> 116 MILLION ON ADS THAT
MENTION SPEAKER PELOSI BY NAME
IN THIS CYCLE.
IF THIS IS ABOUT THE ISSUES, WHY
DON'T YOU MAKE IT ABOUT THE
ISSUES?
>> WE ARE EIGHT DAYS OUT.
DON'T YOU THINK THIS NEED TO
CHANGE?
SHOULDN'T WE PULL ADS.
>> Tucker: WHY DON'T YOU MAKE IT
ABOUT THE ISSUES SAYS THE LADY
WHO SPENT FOUR YEARS SCREAMING
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP THE MAN.
IT'S EMBARRASSING AND SHAMELESS
AND THE SECOND THE MIDTERMS ARE
OVER THEY'LL STOP.
BUT THE POINT IS, AS ALWAYS, ALL
THE JOURNALISTS, JOURNALISTS,
GOT THE SAME MEMO AND ARE ALL
RUNNING WITH THE SAME MEMO OF
COURSE USING EXACTLY THE SAME
WORDS.
ARCUALLY PARKER WROTE, IN 2022
THE GOP SPENT $40 MILLION
VILIFYING PELOSI ON ADS AND ON
FRIDAY HER HUSBAND WAS ATTACKED
BY A HAMMER DO YOU SEE THE
DIRECT CORRELATION.
IF YOU CRITICIZE NANCY PELOSI
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE ENDANGERING HER
FAMILY.
OF COURSE SHE DOES RUN THE
POLITICAL PARTY FACING
REELECTION RIGHT NOW THAT
CONTROLS THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS, THIRD IN LINE TO THE
PRESIDENCY BUT YOU CAN'T
CRITICIZE HER BECAUSE IF YOU DO
YOU'RE JUST LIKE PAUL DEPAPE.
SO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY CLEARLY
NEEDS TO STOP RUNNING
ADVERTISING THAT HURTS DEMOCRATS
AHEAD OF THE MIDTERMS.
PLEASE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM HERE.
NOT THE MENTALLY ILL BLM NUDIST
IN BERKELEY.
SO WHAT THEY'RE REALLY ARGUING
IN THE WAKE OF THIS ATTACK,
WHICH IS AWFUL AGAINST SOMEONE
WHO DID NOT DESERVE IT, WE WANT
TO BE CLEAR, PAUL PELOSI IS A
NICE GUY HE REALLY IS.
BUT ALONG WITH THAT THEY'RE
TELLING YOU YOU CAN'T HAVE FREE
SPEECH.
THEY'RE TELLING US THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF TERRORISM, COMPLETELY
MEANINGLESS PHRASE THAT EMERGED
LIKE A VIRUS OUT OF THE
UNIVERSITY TO INFECT OUR PUBLIC
DISCOURSE, TO SUPPRESS OUR
PUBLIC DISCOURSE.
REUTERS TERRORISM AND EXTREMISM
EXPERTS SAY IT COULD BE AN
EXAMPLE OF THE GROWING THREAT OF
STOW CHAZ PARTICULAR TERRORISM
IN WHICH SOMETIMES UNSTABLE
INDIVIDUALISM ARE INSPIRED BY
HATE SPEECH.
WHAT IS HATE SPEECH BY THE WAY?
ALL OF A SUDDEN EVERYONE IN THE
MEADE WHY HAS, SORT OF WITHOUT
EXPLAINING WHY, AGREE THAT
THERE'S THIS THING CALLED HATE
SPEECH THAT'S REAL AND PROBABLY
ACTIONABLE.
THEY CAN FIND A BILLION DOLLARS
JUDGMENT AGAINST YOU IF YOU
COMMIT HATE SPEECH.
BUT JUST TO REMIND EVERYONE
WATCHING, THERE'S NO SUCH THING
AS HATE SPEECH.
HATE SPEECH IS SPEECH PEOPLE
HATE, USUALLY THE PEOPLE IN
POWER.
THE TRUTH IS, ALL SPEECH, EXCEPT
SPEECH THAT ENCOURAGES PEOPLE TO
EMINENT ILLEGAL ACTION, LIKE GO
SHOOT THAT GUY, SHORT OF THAT
THERE'S NO HATE SPEECH.
ALL IS ALLOWED UNDER THE UNITED
STATES CONS CONSTITUTION WHICH
IS OUR FINAL HOPE.
WHAT THEY'RE TELLING YOU IS THAT
DECENTING IN ANY WAY FROM THE
EDITORIAL POSITIONS OF SAY THE
WASHINGTON POST OR THE DAILY
BEAST OR THE ATLANTIC MAGAZINE,
DISAGREEING WITH THOSE
PUBLICATIONS AND THE CONSENSUS
THEY REPRESENT ISN'T SIMPLY
IMMORAL IT'S VIOLENT.
IT GETS PEOPLE KILLED, THAT'S
THE TERRORISM.
WHEN YOU QUESTION, SAY, COVID
PROTOCOLS OR DRAG QUEEN STORY
HOUR OR THE WAR AGAINST RUSSIA,
YOU ARE EFFECTIVELY SMASHING AN
82 YEAR OLD MAN IN THE HEAD WITH
A HAMMER.
THEY'RE MAKING THAT ARGUMENT.
AND OF COURSE THEY HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO MAKE THAT
ARGUMENT.
DEMOCRATS ARE VERY WORRIED ABOUT
THE COMING ELECTION.
BUT THEY'RE ABSOLUTELY TERRIFIED
THAT ELON MUSK MAY ALLOW PEOPLE
TO CRITICIZE THEM ON TWITTER.
AND THEY KNOW, WHAT REPUBLICANS
DON'T SEEM TO KNOW, WITHOUT
SENSORSHIP THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
CANNOT CONTINUE TO HOLD POWER.
DEMOCRATS UNDERSTAND THAT, THEY
HAVE NOTHING TO OFFER, THEY HAVE
TO STOP YOU FROM ASKING
QUESTIONS.
SO THEY HAVE TO CRUSH ELON MUSK.
NOT BECAUSE HE'S A RIGHT WINGER
BUT BECAUSE HE WILL ALLOW THEIR
OPPONENTS TO SPEAK.
AND OF COURSE THEY ARE USING THE
ATTACK ON POOR PAUL PELOSI TO DO
JUST THAT.
THE NEW YORK TIMES HAS JUST COME
OUT WITH A PIECE THAT SAYS, AND
WE'RE QUOTING, ELON MUSK IN A
TWEET SHARES A LINK FROM A SIGHT
KNOWN TO PUBLIC FAKE NEWS.
REALLY, WHAT DID ELON MUSK DO?
WELL, HE LINKED TO AN ARTICLE
ABOUT HOW PAUL PELOSI CALLED THE
GUY IN HIS HOME A FRIEND.
WELL, THAT'S WHAT THE 911 TAPE
SAYS.
YOU CAN DRAW YOUR OWN
CONCLUSIONS OR NOT.
MAYBE YOU DON'T CARE WHICH IS
ALSO FINE.
HOW IS THAT FAKE?
SEEMS TO BE REAL.
NBC NEWS'S BEN COLUMNS EXPLAINS
MUSK'S TWEETS ARE HOW YOU LOSE A
DEMOCRACY IN THE AGE OF THE
INTERNET.
OH, BY ASKING QUESTIONS.
JIMMY KIMMEL ATTACKED MUSK
PERSONALLY, USED TO BE A COMIC,
SAD TO WATCH THAT DECLINE.
IT'S BEEN INTERESTING KIMMEL
WROTE TO MUSK TO WATCH YOU
BLOSSOM FROM THE ELECTRIC CAR
GUY TO A FULLY FORMED PIECE OF
HUMAN EXCREMENT.
CBS TOLD ITS VIEWERS IN THE WEAK
OF THE ATTACK OF PAUL PELOSI
ELON MUSK CANNOT ALLOW PEOPLE TO
SPEAK FREELY ON TWITTER.
THEY MUST RETAIN WHAT THE FAR
RIGHT CALLS CENSORSHIP.
OH, THE FAR RIGHT.
YOU DON'T NEED TO BE FAR RIGHT
TO IDENTIFY IT AS SENSORSHIP
BECAUSE SENSE ORSHIP IS EXACTLY
WHAT IT IS AND TO RESTATE,
DEMOCRATS COULD NO LONGER EXIST
OR HOLD POWER WITHOUT IT.
THEY NEED CENSORSHIP AND THEY'RE
GOING TRY TO USE THIS HORRIFYING
CRIME TO HOLD ON TO IT.
BUT SOMETHING ELSE IS GOING ON
HERE, TOO, SOMETHING BENEATH
EVEN ALL OF THAT.
OBVIOUSLY BY IMMEDIATELY
POLITICIZING THE ATTACK,
DEMOCRATS GET A LOT.
POTENTIALLY.
BUT THE MAIN THING THEY DO IS
EFFECTIVELY OBSCURE THE DEEPEST
TRUTH OF ALL WHICH IS THAT WHAT
HAPPENED TO PAUL PELOSI'S NOT SO
UNUSUAL ANYMORE.
CRIME IN THIS COUNTRY IS OUT OF
CONTROL BY EVERY MEASURE.
ATTACKS BY THE MENTALLY ILL
HOMELESS, EVEN NON-NUDISTS THAT
DON'T LIVE IN BUSES, BUT THEENT
INIALLY ILL HOMELESS ARE ITS OWN
CATEGORY AND FEATURE OF LIFE IN
THE CITY CONTROLLED BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IF YOU LIVE IN THOSE PLACES NO
MATTER WHO YOU VOTE FOR YOU KNOW
THAT'S TRUE.
GET PUSHED IN FRONT OF A SUBWAY
TRAIN BY ONE, THAT'S ENTIRELY
REAL.
HERE'S ONE RECENT EXAMPLE FROM
CALIFORNIA.
A 54 YEAR OLD MAN AND 22 YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER WERE JUST STABBED
TO DEATH IN A PARKING LOT OF A
COLE'S BY A MENTALLY ILL
HOMELESS MAN.
NOT AN UNUSUAL STORY BUT A
PARTICULARLY AWFUL ONE.
HERE'S THE LOCAL NEWS ACCOUNT.
>> SAY THERE ARE MULTIPLE
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS IN THE AREA
AND PEOPLE ARE KNOWN TO LIVE OUT
OF THEIR CARS IN THE BACK OF
THIS PARTICULAR PARKING LOT.
EVERYONE SAYS THEY'RE SHOCKED BY
THE VIOLENCE.
>> FOR ME I WAS LIKE DUMFOUNDED
LIKE WAIT SOMEONE JUST GOT
STABBED IN DAYLIGHT.
DOESN'T MATTER IF IT'S DAYLIGHT
OR NIGHTTIME BUT THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE HAVE THE AUDACITY SAYS
THEY DON'T CARE.
SO TO FIND OUT WAIT A MINUTE
SOMEWHERE WHERE I GO TO SHOP AND
GET GAS AND MY BANK IS RIGHT
HERE BUT SOME DEAD PERSON IS
RIGHT THERE?
THAT'S INFURIATING AND SAD.
>> Tucker: SO TO RESTATE, CAN
HEART FELT SINCERITY, WE
COULDN'T FEEL WORSE ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO PAUL PELOSI WHO
DIDN'T DESERVE IT.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BE INJURED IN A VIOLENT
CRIME IN 2022, NOT SO SURPRISING
THAT THAT CRIME WAS COMMITTED BY
A MENTALLY ILL HOMELESS MAN,
BECAUSE SO MANY CRIMES ARE
COMMITTED BY MENTALLY ILL
HOMELESS PEOPLE.
A FACT THAT EVERYONE WHO LIVES
IN A CITY UNDERSTANDS PERFECTLY
WELL AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
MAKING IT POSSIBLE, THE LEADERS
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ASSIDUOUSLY IGNORE.
THIS YEAR A MAN NAMED JAMES
ASKED TWO HOMELESS MEN TO MOVE
AWAY FROM HIS DESK AND THEY
VIOLENTLY BEAT HIM WITH A WOODEN
PLANK AND SENT HIM TO THE
HOSPITAL AT 11:00 A.M. IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT.
THIS HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
AND HERE'S THE POINT, THE PSYCHO
DRUG ADLED ZOMBIES WHO DO IT ARE
USUALLY RELEASED THE SAME DAY TO
DO IT AGAIN.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT.
IT'S NOT AN ACCIDENT, IT'S THE
RESULTS OF POLICY, POLICY THAT
NANCY PELOSI SUPPORTS IN HER OWN
CITY.
BUT IN THIS CASE, THE GUY DID
NOT WALK BECAUSE IT HAPPENED AT
NANCY PELOSI'S HOUSE.
SO THE GUY IS STILL IN JAIL.
HE'S NOT BENNING FROM CASHLESS
BAIL.
THE POLICE GOT THERE IN TWO
MINUTES IN SAN FRANCISCO!
THAT'S FOUR TIMES FASTER THAN
THE AVERAGE RESPONSE TIME IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
FOUR TIMES.
SO THE LESSON HEAR COULDN'T BE
MORE OBVIOUS, AND THEIR
SCREAMING IS DESIGNED TO KEEP
YOU FROM REACHING THIS
CONCLUSION.
BUT HERE IT IS.
NANCY PELOSI AND HER PARTY, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, NOT AN
OVERSTATEMENT TO SAY THIS, HAVE
DELIBERATELY CREATED A BREAKDOWN
IN LAW AND ORDER AND SAFETY AND
QUALITY OF LIFE IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
YET, THEY ARE GIVEN SPECIAL
TREATMENT THEMSELVES WHEN IT
HAPPENS TO THEM.
SO YOU CAN GRIEVE THE ATTACK ON
PAUL PELOSI AND SEE IT AS
HORRIFYING, BECAUSE IT IS, AND
STILL UNDERSTAND THAT THE
RESPONSE TO IT WOULD NOT BE
EXTENDED TO YOU.
IT'S A DOUBLE STANDARD.
IT'S A TWO-TIERED SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE.
THAT'S COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE
AND IT'S NOT JUSTICE, IN FACT.
IT'S THE OPPOSITE.
SO THE MEDIA OUGHT TO BE SAYING
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS HAPPENING, THIS CRIME
SPECIFICALLY HAPPENED BUT SO
MANY OTHERS HAVE HAPPENED
BECAUSE OF POLICIES DESIGNED TO
ALLOW THEM TO HAPPEN.
AND SOMEONE IN THE PRESS SHOULD
POINT THAT OUT.
HEY PAUL PELOSI'S NOT THE ONLY
GUY WHO GOT ATTACKED BY A NUT
CASE HOMELESS GUY THIS MONTH.
BUT THEY'RE NOT SAYING THAT.
AND BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT SAYING
THAT, DEMOCRAT POLITICIANS GET
TO SKATE.
AND NOT JUST SKATE BUT TO
GRANDSTAND UNDER REPUBLICAN
VIOLENCE IN WAYS THAT ANY PERSON
WITH A SENSE OF SHAME WOULD BE
TOTALLY INCAPABLE OF DOING.
BECAUSE YOU'D HATE YOURSELF FOR
DOING IT.
BUT THEY DON'T HATE THEMSELVES
THEY'LL SAY WHATEVER IT TAKES.
ON THE VERY SAME DAY THAT BARACK
OBAMA BLAMED REPUBLICANS FOR
ASSAULTING PAUL PELOSI, OBAMA
WAS CAMPAIGNING IN WISCONSIN FOR
TONY EVERS.
DOES THAT NAME SOUND FAMILIAR?
THAT'S THE GOVERNOR WHO LET
HOMICIDAL MOBS TAKE OVER THE
CITY OF KENOSHA TWO YEARS AGO
FOR POLITICAL REASONS.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE'VE GOT POLITICIANS WHO
WORK TO STIR UP DIVISION, TO TRY
TO MAKE US ANGRY AND AFRAID OF
ONE ANOTHER FOR THEIR OWN
ADVANTAGE.
AND ALL OF IT GETS AMPED UP,
HYPED UP, 24/7 BY SOCIAL MEDIA,
BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES THEIR
FOR-PROFIT PLATFORMS THAT MAKE
IT MORE PROFITABLE TO FEED YOU
CONTROVERSY AND CONFLICT INSTEAD
OF FACTS AND TRUTH.
AND SOMETIMES IT CAN TURN
DANGEROUS.
>> Tucker: OH, YOUR SPEECH TURNS
OTHER PEOPLE ARE STIRRING UP
RESENTMENT.
REALLY?
NO PRESIDENT IN AMERICAN HISTORY
EVER CAUSED, INTENTIONALLY
CAUSED MORE RACIAL DIVISION,
MORE RACE HATE THAN BARACK OBAMA
DID.
IT WAS THE KEY TO HIS SECOND
TERM OBVIOUSLY.
BUT THE SOLUTION TO SOMETHING
THAT HE DID IS PROHIBITING YOU
FROM SAYING WHAT YOU THINK.
SHUTTING DOWN YOUR
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHT, YOUR GOD GIVEN RIGHT TO
SAY WHAT YOU THINK IS TRUE IS
ALWAYS THE SOLUTION, INFLATE
WORDS WITH VIOLENCE WHEN IT
SUITS THEM.
IN GEORGIA LAST WEEK BARACK
OBAMA SAID DEMOCRATS, THE PARTY
THAT DEFUNDED THE POLICE, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTIED SOMEHOW HE
SAID BEARS NO RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THE RISE IN VIOLENT CRIME ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY IN FACT OBAMA
PRETENDED DEMOCRATS DID NOT VOTE
TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
WHO VOTED FOR LESS RESOURCES FOR
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT?
YEAH, IT'S LIKE IF YOU'LL SAY
ANYTHING MAYBE IT WORKS.
YEAH.
WHO EVER SEES BALTIMORE AND GARY
INDIANA AND MINNEAPOLIS AND NEW
YORK AND PORTLAND OREGON, HOW
ARE THOSE CITIES DOING?
SPEAKING OF SHAMELESSNESS KATHY
HOCHUL JUST WENT ON AL
SHARPTON'S SHOW TO CLAIM THE
CRIME WAVE THE ONE YOU'RE
WATCHING OR THAT MAY HAVE HURT
YOU OR KILLED ONE OF YOUR
NEIGHBORS IS FAKE.
IN A STATEMENT THAT IS CRAZIER
THAN ALEX JONES HAS EVER
THOUGHT.
>> CONSPIRACY GOING ALL ACROSS
AMERICA TO TRY AND CONVINCE
PEOPLE THAT DEMOCRATIC STRAITS
ARE NOT AS SAFE.
GUESS WHAT, THEY'RE ALSO NOT
ONLY ELECTION DENIERS, THEY'RE
DATA DENIERS.
DATA SHOWS SHOOTINGS AND MURDERS
ARE DOWN IN OUR STATE BY 15% NEW
YORK CITY, DOWN 20% IN LONG
ISLAND WHERE WILL LEE SELL DENY
COMES FROM.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A LIE
ACTUALLY.
NEW YORK IS SO DANGEROUS PEOPLE
ARE LEAVING.
RENTS HAVEN'T GONE DOWN BECAUSE
FOREIGN INVESTORS ARE BUYING UP
ALL THE BUILDINGS BUT PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING NEW YORK IN DROVES.
OF COURSE.
BUT ACCORDING TO KATHY HOCHUL IN
A CLAIM THAT IS TRULY CRAZIER
THAN ANYTHING ELSE JONES HAS
EVER THOUGHT IN THE SHOWER TO
HIMSELF, KATHY HOCHUL IS TELLING
YOU THAT THE DATA ARE FAKE.
SO HERE YOU HAVE A CITY IN
WHICH, NEW YORK CITY, SUBWAY
RIDERSHIP HAS DROPPED BY 40%
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
NOW, ACCORDING TO KATHY HOCHUL,
IT'S NOT BECAUSE SUBWAY
RIDERSHIP IS BEING PUSHED IN
FRONT OF TRAINS PEOPLE BEING
ATTACKED BY MENTALLY HOMELESS.
NO.
IT'S BECAUSE PATIENTLY MILLIONS
OF NEW YORKERS ARE WATCHING FOX
NEWS AND BEING FOOLED BY RIGHT
WING PROPAGANDA INTO THINKING
THE SUBWAY IS DANGEROUS.
THAT'S WHAT SHE'S SUGGESTING.
THIS IS TOO STUPID.
THIS IS A LIE.
VOTERS KNOW IT'S A LIE.
AND WHEN DEMOCRATS GET CRUSHED
IN NEXT WEEK'S MIDTERM IT WILL
BE IN PART BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN CITIES AND STATES RUN BY
LIBERALS UNDERSTAND THAT WHAT
HAPPENED TO PAUL PELOSI COULD
VERY WELL HAPPEN TO TH